(light ethereal music)
We are the
detectives of the past.
And we have to figure
out what happened.
That is what is fascinating
about archaeology.
Peru is super special
archaeologically
because this is one of the
cradles of civilization.
It's where civilization
actually arose from nothing.
A little over 100
years ago, Hiram Bingham
went to Peru and relying
on local knowledge
found this crumbling city in
the middle of the rainforest.
At the time, he used state of
the art photography equipment
to record what was there.
It was the first scientific
archaeological expedition
that National Geographic funded.
And, in some ways,
it helped to launch our
modern age of archaeology.
So the idea of applying new
state of the art technology
to map sites in Peru feels
like a natural extension
of what Hiram Bingham
did over 100 years ago.
One of the dreams of
archaeology has always been
to look from above.
As drones became available,
five or six years ago,
archaeologists jumped
at this opportunity.
Finally, we can fly
above our excavations
and take a picture
that reveals everything
that we have been
seeing from below.
Now, if you simply go up,
up, up, into space
and look down with a camera,
you can at the same time
look at not one square mile,
but many square miles.
And then you can focus
on specific items
that you think are important.
Space archaeology is the study
and the use of satellite images
for mapping ancient
archaeological features
and environmental features
by looking at different
parts of the light spectrum.
We see subtle changes
on the earth's surface
caused by what's buried beneath.
And what satellites
help us to do
is pinpoint areas and we
know to within a few meters
exactly where something is
from thousands of miles away.
We're the generation
with all the tools
and all the technologies
to be able to map sites
and protect them.
And, using these
new technologies,
we have a real chance
to protect and preserve
these sites for
future generations.
(light uptempo electronic music)